[SHOUTING]
Actually, it's Wednesday, but
I did get 1400 people to say
hello to you with VidCon,
which isn't nothing.
So Hank, we're just back
from VidCon, and for your
edification, I have compiled
my top ten VidCon moments.
Number ten is dancing to the
All Caps song, Don't Unplug Me.
and I think as you know I can't
dance, but I am very
passionate about it.
The same way I felt about
French kissing in high school.
[MUSIC]
Number nine.
Meekakitty's velociraptor.
Scary, but also alluring.
Eight, Dan Brown's
announcement of Dan 3.0.
For one year, I am very
literally putting complete
control of my life
in your hands.
Hank, I think Dan 3.0 will be a
fascinating social experiment.
Although I fear that if we did
it, people would just make us
put unicorns on our
head all the time.
Number seven.
Hi I'm Rawn asked me dress up
as a turkey for his big musical
production. and I was pulling
on the turkey costume, and I
was like, Ron, that's fine,
I'm happy to do it,
but I don't know.
Am I supposed to dance?
Am I supposed to get on stage?
Whereupon he turned to a guy
dressed as Batman, pointed at
him, and said Batman, I'm
going to need you to be a
leader in this situation.
Number six.
Hank, singing on stage with
you for the first and
last time in my life.
Put stuff on your head.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to be red.
The color doesn't matter
if it's on your head.
[APPLAUSE]
Number five.
Mass hug at the Nerdfighter
gathering involving
hundreds of Nerdfighters.
Four.
I suppose at this point I
should be used to it, but Ze
Frank gave the most
astonishingly brilliant keynote
address I think I have ever
heard, reminding us that we
don't make or watch videos for
money or subscribers or
reviews, but because we want to
feel what it's like to be other
people and let others feel what
it's like to be us.
Number three.
Just how nice everyone was.
I mean, given the fact that
YouTubers are mostly
introverted, nerdy people who
like to spend their free time
with editing software.
Everyone was incredibly nice.
Everyone hung out.
Famous people didn't act
like they were famous.
And the whole vibe of the event
was so wonderfully supportive
and collaborative.
Number two.
Two words.
Double Rainbow.
The Gregory Brothers of
Auto-Tune the News singing
a song they had written
mere hours before.
This is a song that goes
out to all the rainbows.
Also the ladies.
But mostly the rainbows.
Double rainbow all the way
across the sky, yeah yeah.
It's so intense.
[MUSIC AND CHEERING]
And number one.
Seeing my little brother sing
about particle physics in front
of a thousand people who
loved every second of it.
A quark is a fundamental
constituent of matter,
observed in 1968 through
deep elastic scatter.
We found that protons aren't
as simple as we thought.
We thought they were solid
particles, but they are not.
Nerdfighters.
Hank, thank you for all the
thousands of hours you
spent making VidCon
as awesome as it was.
It felt like my favorite parts
of the internet existed in real
life for three whole days.
Nerdfighters, if you were at
VidCon, whether in real life or
on live stream, please let us
know what your favorite parts
of the conference were.
And let us know, if Hank is
crazy enough to do this whole
thing again, who and what you'd
like to see at VidCon 2011.
So Hank, thanks again,
and I will see--
Hey listen, I'm happy for you,
and I don't know if you
finished, but the Vlog Brothers
have one the most subscribed
YouTube channels of all time.
That's right, the Vlog Brothers
just broke into the top
100 most subcribed.
Thank you all for subscribing.
Particularly thanks to
Ray William Johnson,
Charlieissocoollike,
and Meekakitty, but
thanks to everybody.
You're so awesome.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.